[Music]
I have a child
[Music]
this is Justin hey whould filling in for
our reviewer brett todd little things
make all the difference in divinity
original sin - while this role-playing
masterpiece from Larian studios hits the
high notes as well as the low in its
epic saga about divine ascension quieter
moments resonate just as much as epic
God killing scenes but pulling at your
heartstrings is not all that the game
does well Larian has crafted one of the
finest role-playing epics of all time
packed with meaningful choices evocative
writing and superb acting all of which
combine to form a wholly believable
world the detailed and free-flowing
combat engine provides a challenging and
rewarding turn-based tactical battles
and add tension to every action and
every member of your party feels more
like a real individual than the usual
collection of buffs and numbers found in
most RPGs as with its predecessor from
2014 divinity original sin - setting
remains the D&D infused fantasy land of
Rivlin but the clock has been moved
forward centuries so you don't
technically need any familiarity with
the first game you take on the role of a
sorcerer a name referring to those that
draw arcane power from a mystic material
called source but deploy source powers
and bizarre creatures show up to kill
everyone in sight
this because of this you're viewed is a
danger to society by a governing body of
inquisitors who claim to serve the
divine order and protect society by
rounding up and curing sorcerers the
story begins with you and the other
members of your four-person party being
sent off to the island prison of fort
joy with source blocking callers around
your necks you soon realize that you
have a greater destiny to fulfill
however you and the other members of
your party discover that you are God
Wilkin demigods who have a chance to
ascend and basically replace the seven
gods under threat by creatures from the
void that's where I come in
with my help you will be capable of so
much more than strumming a lute for a
few gold coins this epic saga is a big
undertaking expect to use up the better
part of 60 to 70 hours to complete the
main quest line and a good portion of
many of the side quests the story isn't
just extensive though it's detailed and
gripping largely due to how it avoids
good versus evil fantasy archetypes come
in two RPGs while you start off with
persecuted sorcerers on one side and
oppressive Magisters on the other events
soon carry you into a world of
unrelenting grey where most people are
trying to do the right thing yet failing
miserably even the pallid infection that
shows up in the game as heroes turn into
blinkered zealots basically nobody can
be trusted not even your comrades is
only one of you can ascend to godhood
you're left wide open when it comes to
determining a course of action with
nothing in the game forcing you down any
particular road play good play evil play
something in between this approach is
incredibly freeing it lets you guide
your character and party according to
your own moral compass or a lack of one
I'd forgive this soul punishment must
fit the crime this doesn't
[Music]
anyone who marches at the head of an
undead host deserves whatever punishment
they get freedom with character design
and development really boosts this
feeling every hero comes with a wide
range of core attributes plus civil
abilities combat abilities skills
talents source abilities and more five
racial choices blend the expected humans
and dwarves with the offbeat elves who
consume body parts undead who pick locks
with their skeletal fingers and hide
their boney faces to avoid scaring NPCs
you can roll your own protagonist or
choose from one of six provided
characters representing each race each
of which comes with a specialized
storyline that immerses you deeper into
the saga the voice that rings inside me
now is darker than any that came before
almost caused a bunch of my fans to rip
each other to pieces but you can trust
me I've got it under control even then
you're allowed a free hand to customize
everything you're also able to tell
those joining your party what sort of
adventurer you want to employ picking
from a wide range of classes so if you
want to take on say the arrogant lizard
red prince or the sinister elf Sibyl
you're not locked into a set class as
you would be in most RPGs
at a glance combat is not much different
from many other computer RPGs battle is
our turn-based with action points
governing all activities but where
divinity original sin too differs from
its peers is with the importance it
gives to terrain and environmental
elements pools of water can be frozen
into slippery sheets of ice high ground
gives boost to damage and low ground
restricts it enemies turn these
battlefield features into advantages too
as a result battles are damn tough many
play out like puzzles where you almost
have to play through and lose at least
once in order to figure out how the
enemy will hit you and determine a way
to counter their moves for a second or
third or fourth try
but quest design is less forgiving when
it comes to second chances you can and
will screw up but the adventure rolls on
regardless an NPC can be randomly killed
shutting down a quest before it starts
sometimes you simply cannot succeed at a
skill check necessary to move a
particular adventure along failing
persuasion checks is fairly routine
forcing you to figure out another way
forward and damn the consequences where
most RPGs let you push on and experience
almost everything in a single
playthrough it's impossible to
experience all that this one has to
offer in one play or maybe even two or
three quests are not perfect though
the journal system of tracking them
isn't nearly robust enough to keep up
with how many you have going on at any
given time you can't search it and even
worse key elements are frequently not
included in the text descriptions as a
result of this quest confusion you can
spend too much time wandering around
searching for a key location that for
reasons unknown was not noted on the map
some will believe this to be a good
thing that we finally have a serious RPG
that doesn't hold the hands of its
players but this issue seems more like a
disconnect between how quests are
offered up during the game and how
they're tracked in the journal than any
commitment to old-school difficulty in
addition to the expansive single-player
campaign you can also play with friends
cooperatively or dive into an even truer
pen-and-paper role-playing simulation
with game master mode but this is the
kind of game that you're best off
playing online with friends the involved
story and the necessity to use teamwork
in combat make the game too challenging
if your adventuring with uncooperative
strangers
[Music]
from lonely farmhouses through pitched
battles with gods and far-flung
dimensions divinity original sin - is
one of the most captivating role-playing
games ever made its immaculately
conceived an emotion wrought fantasy
world topped by brilliant tactical
combat make it one of the finest games
of the year thus far and it has to be
regarded as an instant classic in the
pantheon of RPG greats
[Music]